(instrumental music)
- I literally think I
have one of the best ideas
for a social network.
I really think it's the best idea.
I want to start a social network
that only lets you post...
You've got your perspective.
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
YouTube, what's up?
So so grateful that you clicked
and you're about to
watch a new YouTube video
but before you do
two one two
nine three one
five seven three one.
That is my texting community platform.
I'm doing a lot of one on
one engagement in there
and also access opportunity
first looks in that environment.
Two one two
nine three one
five seven three one.
Join it now
and now to the video you've
been wanting to watch.
(melancholic music)
We have to change the
conversation in our society.
Until this society puts happiness
as the north star of success, not money,
we will continue to
not be happy deep down.
I don't hate trying to win,
I hate knowing that I
know tons of millionaires
who are borderline suicidal.
I hate to know that it doesn't solve shit.
My favorite "I'll rather
cry in my Ferrari".
Are you a fucking idiot?
(audience laughing)
Crying is not interesting
in any fucking vehicle.
(audience laughing)
It's far more exciting to be
happy taking the fucking bus.
We have to reform the conversation
in our society, period.
(vocalizing)
Yup.
TikTok and LinkedIn.
You've heard me say it over
and over for the last three months.
For everybody here who's B2B,
I can't push you enough on LinkedIn.
I can't
It's just a big deal.
Instagram is now favoring
images over video.
Very recent change.
That's why you're seeing more quotes
and cartoons from me
and a little less video.
I keep pushing this, watch what I'm doing,
not what I'm saying.
This is the first time
I'm saying this publicly
and this is not super public
but it's hard core to look like look at
how many times has he
posted video versus pictures
in the last 200 days.
That's some real tedious
work but it's all there.
My big hope, just to make it competitive,
is that TikTok adds pictures.
I think that's the big
thing sitting available.
Will TikTok do the reverse
of what Instagram did to Snapchat?
'cause Instagram's already testing
a TikTok competitor in Brazil.
Right now.
Right this second.
I want TikTok to do the reverse move.
I think if TikTok adds pictures,
I think you've got a real fight.
That would be fun to watch.
I like mega fights.
Let me tell you why for
everybody TikTok matters.
Whether TikTok hits your demo,
whether TikTok disappears like Vine,
it's completely irrelevant.
The skill set of
communicating in that format
will map somewhere else.
This is why everybody
who pissed on Snapchat
and didn't do it
and then stories came for
Instagram and they all hit me up
and said "see, Gary? Glad
I didn't listen to you
"and waste my time the last
two years on Snapchat",
I'm like "Really?" 'cause guess what?
You still have no skill set on how to do
Instagram stories and now
it really fucking matters.
And you would have learned
the ability of how to create
in a stories environment
on Snap that you would have transferred.
Everybody has to learn
why TikTok is resonating
because every one of those people 12 to 20
are gonna be your customer in 11 years
and the format in which
they would like to be sold
your product is going to
have way more nuances in
the way they were built by loving TikTok.
MTV, every single business
man and woman in their forties
dresses the way they do now
because of hip hop culture.
If you didn't believe in
hiphop in 1995, six, seven,
eight, nine, you left
a lot of understanding
of consumer behavior.
The MTV hip hop nuances
are now the establishment.
The way that TikTok
creates and communicates,
in a decade or two, will be
a establishment of communication.
- [Deep Voiced Man] That's
a really good point.
- Right?
It's an interesting point, right?
- Yeah.
It's about creating fluency.
- Thank you. That's a great way to put it.
That's the point.
That's why I became me
because I was never
scared to go on Socialcam,
which was hot for seven months,
which became the beginning of
me understanding DailyBooth.
Do you remember DailyBooth?
Which was a laptop
version of a selfie a day,
which then became Instagram.
It's the skill set of
being a communicator.
(melancholic music)
Period.
I can give you the hacks.
I'm telling you right now, I can give you
the fucking hacks, I
can give you the decks,
I can give you the
details, you can just copy
everything I'm doing.
The problem is what are
you gonna put in there?
I can tell you where to post and how.
I can tell you, like
I'll tell you right now,
that TikTok and LinkedIn
are so under priced
with their organic reach that
you should be posting on there
because you will learn how to
communicate in a modern world,
TikTok, or you will get so much awareness.
You could have no LinkedIn account go home
from this conference,
create one, post a post,
write four sentences on your thoughts
about you your business, whatever,
and get way more people seeing that
than you could ever imagine.
You can't do that on Instagram any more.
It's matured.
You can't do that on Twitter any more.
There is no making the
first video on YouTube
and getting 4,000 people to just see it.
The organic nature of average content,
because actually ironically with YouTube
if you make some fire you
can have your first sub.
And there's some gal I think
who just got two million
subscribers off of two videos
but I'm talking average content.
You can put mundane,
simple content on LinkedIn
and TikTok right now and
get enormous organic reach.
I was the beneficiary of
this on Twitter, on YouTube,
on Snap.
I've lived this.
People are like "Gary Vee,
how much fucking investment
"do you have in TikTok?"
Zero, dick!
Goose.
Nothing.
The biggest ROI for me is
being historically correct.
I could give two fucks if any
of you assholes go on TikTok.
I care about documenting it
when it's proven to be true.
Period.
I want to be historically correct.
Would I love everybody in here to do it?
Of course.
I want to get your email
in three weeks saying
"How the fuck did you know?".
I want you to win.
There's so much abundance.
All of you winning isn't
gonna take away from my views.
I want you to win
and I want to give you
that advice for free.
Over and over and over again
like I've been doing for
the last decade.
(audience cheering)
Help me, Birmingham.
Help me.
Help me understand when
it's free, and consistent,
and consistent, and free, and then,
because you get older, you've
been proven to be right,
and right, and right,
and yet for all the
hands that just went up,
none of them are posting
45, 50 times a day?
This is what got me to Mindset.
I'm like, right, it's
not just taking the horse
and bringing it to the water
and getting it to drink it.
It's also talking to the horse
about their fucked up dad.
It's about "Hey, horse, I get it."
Listen, you want to get real
ROI from this conference?
Go home and ask yourself
why are you not posting
on every platform every day?
You don't have time?
Fuck you.
You didn't grow up with it?
You're not used to it? You
didn't grow up with it?
You didn't grow up driving,
you fucking figured it out.
(audience laughing)
Tell me.
Help me understand why.
What, it takes you long
to get your make up right
and the lighting?
How about don't worry about your make up
and when somebody says you look like shit
reply to them "Go fuck yourself".
(audience laughing and cheering)
(instrumental music)
Back to the club idea,
I had this idea that was mix of Soho House
and Night Life.
This was a really interesting idea.
I'm curious to see how
you guys think about this,
I'll give you an idea of how
I think about innovating,
where the culture is right now.
I want to start a club called Tuesday
and it opens at 6 a.m. and you walk in
and you can't leave
until 6 a.m. Wednesday.
You can't leave.
- [Woman] Why you can't leave?
- You can't leave.
- [Woman] But why?
- Because that's the club.
If you ever leave you're
never allowed to come back.
- [Woman] What will we do in there, guys?
- I want to make it super restrictive.
Think about everybody here.
Giving up your entire
Tuesday, that's absurd.
It's a complete brain fuck,
which is exactly why
I think it would work.
- [Tom] That would work.
- It would, right, Tom?
It would, right?
Here's why it would work.
Here's how I always think.
I hate focus groups of one
but it's funny to have you
here where you said something,
I'm probably mishearing it.
Number one thing I push against,
don't be a focus group of
one. I wouldn't do that.
That doesn't mean anything.
On the flip side,
I'm almost wondering if I
don't have any feelings left.
If I'm so detached
and letting it run through
me that when I think,
I'm thinking at scale of consumer.
When I come up with ideas
that say make me go this.
If Tom and I were hanging out,
if this was exactly happening,
I've never thought of that
and we're just hanging
and he's like "Hey, by the way,
did you hear about Tuesday?"
I'm like "No", he's like
"There's a fucking club
"that opened in New York or
in L.A. It's called Tuesday",
I'm like "What is it?"
"You walk in at 6 a.m.,
it's like a Soho House,
"there's rooms and showers
for people, whatever,
"and you can't leave until Wednesday."
I'd be like "That's fucking amazing."
Here's why it's really amazing.
I think one of the most
interesting things I've
ever seen in my life is
when people go on collective
business trips or other kinds of trips.
If this crew went for a week
to Wine Country in Spain
and spent all our time together.
You'll love this, D-Rock.
I'm still friends with kids
I went to college with.
I went to a hood college.
A lot of these kids got
kicked out of school.
One of my friends that I
talked to today got kicked
out of school seven weeks
after our Freshman year.
I'm still friends with him.
I've always thought that
the first month of college
is this crazy thing.
That people make true life
long friends in the first
30 days of their freshman year in college.
If you surveyed a lot you'd be stunned how
many people have
and I think it's this big shift.
It's that spending a ton of
time I've made some real friends
and had some real moments
on this Australian trip
I took for 17 days that I
mentioned to a lot of you
buying wine in 2002 at South by Southwest
just two, three days in
the evenings with guys
and gals jamming.
So I want to force that.
I think that you come in to
the club on Tuesday at six,
I don't think that people
realize what 24 hours
actually could look
like if you're captive.
I think a lot of people
go to Soho House and clubs
and golf and do a ton of things to network
but you're there for an hour and a half
and it's width, it's not depth.
I think you walk in and
you know you're fucked.
And it's also very disruptive.
It's like how I kind of brought
up February today, right?
Notice how February is second,
notice how mine's Tuesday?
Same theme.
Can't fuck up Monday, too much stress,
I'm gonna go to Tuesday, right?
It's cool, right?
I haven't been able to let this idea go.
I've been sitting on it for a while now.
I literally think I have
one of the best ideas
for a social network.
I'm disappointed and
intrigued by the fact...
- [Young Man] I've started building it.
- One?
- [Young Man] Yep.
- [Woman] Do you know it?
- Yeah I shared it.
- I really think it's the best idea.
I want to start a social
network that only lets you
post once every 24 hours.
That's the restriction.
- [Young Man] We're close.
- The quality of that content
I think is extraordinary.
You're stuck.
And by the way, the depth of the content,
if I'm stuck ever 24 hours
and it becomes Instagram...
"Happy birthday Tom",
that's way bigger than
writing him a letter.
He's like "Holy fuck", right?
Like the depth.
You have 365 posts a year.
The quality would be fucking bonkers.
- [Tom] Yeah, I think you're right.
That's a pretty good idea.
- I think people would really like it.
I think it would really really work.
- [Tom] Yeah, you just gave cache
to a digital item.
- Which is what we all want.
By the way, I would
follow 1000 more people.
- [Woman] If they only post once.
- Right?
When I was ideating this seven years ago
I was like "Oh, and I would
probably follow Snoop."
I don't really give a fuck
about Snoop all that much
but fuck it.
One time a day?
I think it would become
everybody's biggest platform
based one like,
how I can feel my
chemicals think about this.
- [Southern Man] In
Australia you said that.
- This is back to the world is abundant.
You can only get so many things.
So I'm just really passionate
about sharing my best ideas.
I mean I'm right about that
that's a trillion dollar idea.
We're not talking about a
million bucks on that one.